one thing urban meyer is learning
shireen
you know what when you are the head
coach of a major college program
you don't face the same type of media
scrutiny that you do when you're the
coach of an nfl team the local market
isn't as
friendly
the national media is more quick to get
involved and show up and start asking
some tough questions and you know we saw
it yesterday with the interrogation of
urban meyer regarding the hiring of
chris doyle the former strength coach at
iowa who left under circumstances of
allegations of racially charged comments
and mistreatment of players and there
was a 1.1 million dollar settlement an
investigation that seemed to implicate
chris doyle who denied any role in any
sort of wrongdoing well the fritz
pollard alliance
which
praised the jaguars
for their search that led to the hiring
of urban meyer and trent balcke even
though neither are minorities the fritz
paul alliance came out today with this
statement at a time when the nfl has
failed to solve its problem with racial
hiring practices it's simply
unacceptable to welcome chris doyle into
the ranks of nfl coaches doyle's
departure from the university of iowa
reflected a tenure riddled with poor
judgment and mistreatment of black
players his conduct should be
disqualifying for the nfl as it was for
the university of iowa urban meyer's
statement i've known chris for close to
20 years reflects the good old boy
network that is precisely the reason
there is such a disparity in employment
opportunities for black and and making
that even more significant the fact that
rod graves just a few weeks ago said
he thought the jaguars did all the right
things in the hiring of urban meyer and
trent bauke and now all the wrong things
in the opinion of rod graves in the
hiring of chris doyle charade
yeah first of all mike jacksonville
absolutely knew what it was getting into
when it hired urban meyer and gave him
the keys to the organization frankly and
this is a guy who had zach smith on his
on his staff forever and we know how
that turned out for for ohio state and
so now he's hired a friend who he did
not work with it at
utah as we first thought as as he made
it sound in his statement yesterday but
he's hired his good friend to be the
strength and conditioning coach and and
what's going to be interesting to me is
does this turn free agents away from
jacksonville they say i don't want to
come there because of this hiring is he
eventually going to have to farm now the
draft you don't have as much
say in where you go obviously but i am
interested mike if free agents turn
their uh
cheek to the jacksonville say we're not
coming there with this tire of chris
doyle
would it be something if one of the
players that they draft in any round
says i'll just sit the year out and
re-enter the draft next year i'm not
going to go there and deal with that guy
what if there's somebody from iowa that
they draft who dealt with chris doyle
who was offended by or mistreated by
chris doyle and says no i'm just not
going to do it now again he denies it
but he got paid a significant amount to
go away
rod graves has some strong allegations
in his statement and urban meyer as i
said learning that there will be far
greater scrutiny at the nfl level than
there was in gainesville i mean you're
the emperor of gainesville when you're
the head coach at the university of
florida and your team is winning no one
is going to question you no one is going
to scrutinize you no one is going to
investigate whether or to what extent
you're harboring players on your team
who have anti-social tendencies that
they may be acting upon and aaron
hernandez say no more than him and
whatever it was that he may have been
doing down there that no one was looking
into it ohio state did the various
things that occurred the assistant coach
there the thing that led to a brief
suspension of urban meyer in his final
year with the team and it's only going
to be worse and sharing the next item
i'm going to post at pft as soon as
we're done tonight because someone told
me about this earlier today
it wasn't addressed in the rodgrave
statement but urban meyer said he said
that he was with chris doyle 20 years
ago at the university of utah where
meyer was the head coach
and doyle was the top strength coach
and that's just wrong it's factually
incorrect their paths
did not overlap
at the university of utah
i don't know
what defect there is
that causes someone now maybe he
honestly and genuinely misremembers
but my god that it seems like i remember
people that i worked with 20 years ago i
know who i did work with i know who i
didn't work with and you you develop
relationships you know it's an intense
setting you're around each other all the
time if they never actually worked
together at the university of utah you
would think that's something he would
remember
well and i think what urban meyer is
finding out and going to quickly find
out as you said first of all the media
because kudos to the jacksonville media
for asking the questions that they that
they asked they were hard questions and
they were on him and it wasn't just one
question it was multiple questions so
kudos to jacksonville media for sticking
in there and asking those hard questions
but second all they're going to find out
that players aren't going to put up with
some of the stuff that that chris doyle
did at iowa and got away with i think
that's not going to fly in the nfl and
it's going to be over in a hurry and
like i said free agents probably won't
go there but
current players on jacksonville aren't
going to put up with that either mike
it's just not going to happen this is a
different league than college football
it's it's way different and things are
going to be different
for urban meyer in the nfl and if he
hasn't figured that out already he
probably will and i'm sure that chris
doyle was very good at his job i mean he
stayed for 20 years for a guy for a head
coach who's been mentioned for head
coaching jobs in the nfl for a really
long time i'm sure he was good at his
job there are a lot of strength and
conditioning coaches out there mike who
are really good at what they do and
there would have been better hires for
jacksonville that wouldn't have brought
this scrutiny with him to the team
and here's the difference when you're in
gainesville and it's reporters from the
gainesville sun and they start asking
you questions you don't like you dress
them down during the press conference
you grab them afterward and you say
you're going to revoke their credentials
you start calling the editor i'm not
saying any of this is right i'm just
saying this is what happens when you're
the king of a college football program
you don't get questioned the way that
you get questioned when you're the head
of an nfl program because there are
things you can do when people ask you
questions you don't like i'm not saying
it's right i'm just saying it's
different and i'm not saying he ever did
it in gainesville maybe he never had to
do it maybe that's part of the privilege
the reporters know if i start asking the
head of the football program at the
university of florida tough questions
i'm going to be covering middle school
baseball before you know it so uh that
that fear is not shared by the press
corps in jacksonville or by the folks
who cover the nfl nationally and hey
that hey we may never get urban meyer on
the program
we got to call it like we see it if
somebody's saying something that isn't
true you know we're going to point that
out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports